دوري المجموعات في كاس العالم سرقاطع اكثر
من نصفه واشكال المجموعات والمتاهلين بدات
تتضح شويه شويه والمباريات بدات تزيد
حماستها وخطورتهم اليوم مثلا مليان وفي
اربع مباريات تقال لكن في كمان بكره
مباراه نقدر نقول عنها انها ثقيله جدا
ويمكانيه من تقول لها منه ثاني تحديدا
فالخصمين هم امريكا وايران الدوله الزين
السياسيه بينهم عقود مما صنع الحداد واللي
رياضيا كمان بينهم ثار وسبق وتواجهم
التعليقات والترقب والتوتر جاستن بيزيدوا
كل مجال بس بتجرب المباراه وخلينا نقول
للاستفزازات حتى من الجانبين شغاله وبدات
من عند امريكا اللي اتحاد كره القدم فيها
نشر اكثر من صوره
لمباريات الفريق في كاس العالم الدور
الثاني ومثل مو شايفين صوره العلم
الايراني بدون شعار الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
وقال ان هذه طريقته في دعم الاحتجاجات
اللي مولعه في ايران من سبتمبر ضد النظام
وممارساته
بس على فكره اتحاد كره القدم الامريكي رجع
عدل الصوره ونشر العلم الايراني بشعار
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الرسمي على احدى
الصور اللي حاططها خلفيه لحسابه على تويتر
من بعد ما ايران قدمت شكوى للفيفا طلبت
فيها بطرد امريكا من كاس العالم وحرمانها
من 10 مباريات جيه واتهمتها بازاله اسم
الله من علمها العلاقات الامريكيه
الايرانيه عمرها ما كانت جيده لكنها الان
نكمل في مرحله من مراحلها الصعبه يعني
عدوا باقات او نوصفها بانها افضل فا
سياسيا الدنيا مولعه والرياضيين اللي
هيفوز في المباراه بكره بيتاهل الدوره 16
في المباراه الحرفيا هتكون نار لكن كل هذا
البتراء تساؤل بيفرد نفسه صراحه المواجهه
الرياضيه ولا سياسيه
من الدوحه اللاعب الدولي السابق دكتور
تركي العواد اهلا فيك معنا دكتور تركي كيف
الاجواء عندك فقط
خليني اسالك طيب
ان شاء الله ايه حماس جدا ان شاء الله خير
طيب اذا نرجع نتكلم عن موضوعنا اللي هو
الخلافات هذه السياسيه والكلام ده كله
الفيفا دائما جالسه تتكلم تقول انه هذه
رياضه استمتعوا بالرياضه اتركوا عنكم
السياسه لكن فعليا الكل بيتكلم عن مباراه
بكره وكانها معركه فهل فعليه نقدر نقول
انه لا ما فيها بلا مباراه بكره ما لها
علاقه في السياسه حطوا السياسه على جنب يا
جماعه
لا ساره هي كاس العالم هذه بدات نسخه هذه
مش هذه النسخه اعتقد عدد كبير من النسخ بس
يمكن نحنا ما تابعنا بشكل كبير يعني
تصريحات الا هذه البطوله يعني السياسه
كانت داخله من قبل حتى تبدا هذه البطوله
اخراج روسيا من تصفيات كاس العالم قبلها
وايضا مطالبه باخراج ايران مع المظاهرات
ومحساميني وما حدث في ايران كثير من
الاشياء اضافه الى الدول الاوروبيه
كثير من الاشياء اللي انت قاعد تشوفها هي
سياسه سياسه سياسه وليس لها علاقه ابدا في
الرياضه شفنا منتخب الالماني وضع الي
يديناهم على همم
الوجه كثير من الاشياء فهذه ايضا امتداد
لهذا الموضوع لكن اللي صار اليوم انه تدخل
رياضي زياده عن اللزوم وبدات المشكله من
مدرب السابق لمنتخب امريكا
كليزمان وهو لاعب معروف وكان مدرب المنتخب
الامريكي وانتقد المنتخب الايراني يفوز
المره اللي يعني قبل يومين على منتخب ويلز
وقال له هدف فوز لا اخلاقي وانه ضغطوا على
الحكم لطرد اللاعب وانه هذا الانتصار
حقيقي انتصار يعني غير مستحقه بدات
المشكله بينه وبين كروش اللي هو مدرب
منتخب ايران فبدات طبعا هي بكل تاكيد لها
امتدادات كبيره امتدادات سياسيه همم نتكلم
عن الملف النووي والمظاهرات وغير من
الاشياء اللي ما لها داعي ان احنا
نستحضرها في هذه المرحله لكن زائد الموضوع
ان المباراه ثلاث نقاط وهذه الثلاث نقاط
تاهل الى دور ال16 بكل تاكيد كل منتخب
يحاول يرمي اكثر ما يقدر يحصله على
المنتخب الاخر على الاقل في نفسه ومحاوله
انه يلعب مباراه يعني قادر يفوز فيها
وقادر انه يضغط نفسيا وشفنا الاداء النفسي
والقوه المعنويه فازت كثير من المنتخبات
مقابل المنتخبات اخرى كامل اضعف نفسيا
وخسرت المباراه
نفسيه يعني الاثنين داخلين مشحونين فعلا
غير ان الضغط الرياضي عليهم في الضغط
النفسي الناس مثلا كثير من المقالات اللي
قراتها كانت بتركز على المباراه اللي
لعبوها الطرفين سنه 98 وانتهت بفوز ايران
والكل شايفين انه هذه المباراه هي رد على
هذيك المباراه يعني
ما في رد ولا شيء يعني هذه مباراه مختلفه
المباراه الماضيه كانت مباراه من ضمن
المجموعات قيمتها مش كبيره هذه المباراه
اللي يفوز يتاهل مختلفه حتى بالنسبه
للتاريخ بالذات للمنتخب الايراني منتخب
الايراني ومنتخب الاسيوي من الموجودين
اللي ما تاهل الدور الثاني السعوديه تاهلت
استراليا كوريا واليابان في مناسبات سابقه
ولكن همم يعني ايران رغم انه تاهلت نفس
عدد المرات اللي تاهلت استراليا والسعوديه
لانها عمرها ما تتاهل للدور الثاني لذلك
هذه المباراه بالنسبه لها المباراه لا
تقبل القسمه على اثنين همم هذيك المباراه
حق 98 في ال همم بيقولوا انه همم في مشكله
في الصوت عندنا بس
احنا ما احنا سامعينك دكتور تركي
الاتصالات
[موسيقى]
عن ترديد ال- ال- النشيد الوطني لاحظنا
كثير من الضغوط الكبير الموجوده في
الاحتياط عندهم لذلك هذه المره او
المباراه المباراه الماضيه معه ويلز هم
غنوا ولكن بدون حماس يعني هما غنوا فقط
عشان ما يتعرضوا لاي مشاكل وايضا هذه
مباراه قد تكون همم نفس الموضوع لكن بعض
اللاعبين كان عندهم الشجاعه عن المسرحون
انهم مع المظاهرات ومع همم يعني الشعب
الايراني فلذلك هي همم يعني سياسه زي ما
قلت ساره همم
اكيد نحن نستنى المزيد من الحماس كمان فيه
كاس العالم هذا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من الدوحه اللاعب السعودي الدولي
السابق دكتور تركي العواد شكرا لك